literally CEO of Google CEO of slack
number three guy at Facebook just
back-to-back-to-back the CEO of Google
was the one getting grilled yeah so I
got a Rupert Murdoch story cuz he said
Murdoch I'm so impressed with this dude
so he gets a lot of hate because like
his business practices and whatnot
people think he's like a tyrant in a way
he is and he is and like the show
success succession is basically about
their family good show so we had this
opportunity to pitch Rupert Murdoch
so Michael who's my investor comes to me
he says hey we got invited to this thing
basically every year during CES Rupert
Murdoch brings all the CEOs of his
companies through News Corp so they own
Wall Street Journal I think or York New
York Post at Vox and sky and then they
own penguin publishing right I own
realtor.com so he is the media mogul
right like that's cool
so basically once a year they all get
together it's during CES they go to the
Wynn and they rent out the entire top
floor of Wynn and so all the rooms there
are all the execs and they have the
biggest suite the penthouse suite of the
Wynn and what they do is they and I
really admire this they go from 8 a.m.
to about 7 p.m. every single day for two
days straight and every hour is just
they just bring in a speaker not like a
speaker it's like a an industry leader
from something and they just they just
grill them so it's like you you start by
just telling me a little bit about your
business and there's 30 minutes of Q&A
from the CEOs of all these companies
because they're trying to figure out
okay how do we play into this so when I
was there it was like literally CEO of
Google CEO slack number three guy at
Facebook just back-to-back-to-back the
CEO of Google was the one getting
grilled yeah he would go and he was
explained here's what here's where we're
going next year because these are big
media partners for them they they want
to have these media partners working
with them so they'll say here's what
we're going next year and but it's off
the record right so it's more candid
than you're ever gonna get these guys
and I they told me you can just come for
your slot you know this 45 minute slot
Rupert's there though but I was like I'm
sitting here the whole day like this is
why
I need to sit there because we were
gonna present at the end of the day and
so we had access so I just sat there at
8:00 a.m. I'm there with my seat so
here's what I noticed during the day a
lot of the CEOs you know they'd be
interested in certain people but for the
most part you know they get hungry they
go to the bathroom Rupert Murdoch I
don't how old these guys like 80s like
he looks old and he is old and that guy
sat right up front with a
paper-and-pencil did not get up did not
take a break he was the mostest didn't
take a piss he was the most attentive he
asked the best questions he was like a
machine and I was like that's why this
guy's Rupert Murdoch I was so impressed
by this guy his just endurance really
and it also just his level of focus
where everybody else was wandering
throughout the day cuz that's what you
normally do and that's kind of
contagious did he ask what I loved how
the leader was like on point because it
held everybody else like closer to that
standard
did he ask questions he asked good
questions yeah what's funny cuz if
you're the CEO of one of his companies
are already maybe a billion some of them
might be billion M Europe you're you're
up there I don't forbid it but yeah
you're maybe doing super well if you
felt I could be like your it was like
the CEO of Fox Studios like oh yeah we
make these movies for this year and it's
like oh whatever you know Marvel but
like it's like these are big individual
brands you're you're a big you're a big
swing and dick yeah big guy so that was
incredible I just thought that was
really cool and I gotta give him props
for that it was very impressed that's
crazy
[Music]
you